- Is there a possibility
that if we sniff each other
that one person might
smell really different?
- Go ahead.
(sniffing)
- Now, I'm like, I hope I smell good.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together seven Satanists.
- I'm a Satanist.
- I am a Satanist.
- I am a Satanist
- [Narrator] One of them is a Christian.
If the group discovers who the liar is
they will split a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the odd one out?
- So how does everyone identify
in the sense of are you atheist, agnostic?
- I'm an Atheistic Satanist
from the Satanic Temple.
- Also atheist, TST.
- Yep. Same here.
- Yeah, same.
(group chattering)
I was thinking there was gonna be
some Church of Satan people here.
- Same, or self-identified (indistinct)
- I'm more traditional Church
of Satan, kind of mentality.
I actually identify as a Luciferian Witch.
I practice a lot of magic and occultism.
- I love your vibe by the way.
- Oh, thank you.
- Everyone looks amazing.
- Everyone looks great.
- I feel very underdressed.
- Going in I was especially
suspicious of Lisa
because ballet flats.
- I actually learned about
Satanism from a Jubilee video
and it's been about six months.
- Oh, wow.
- So really props to you guys
are introducing me to it.
- Officially, I've only been
Satanist for about a year.
I kind of had to deal with
some former Christian,
like religious, trauma to get there.
- I'm really similar. I
actually grew up Christian
and it wasn't until college
where I started exploring
my queerness more and stepping into it
I just didn't wanna believe in something
that was gonna damn me
to Hell for who I loved.
- I joined The Temple a
little over a year ago.
In general I love Halloween
and anything spooky.
So, I was kind of just
drawn to it, to begin with.
Reading the Temple's tenets
and learning more about it.
It just really resonated with me.
- Shelby's body language kind of conveyed
that she was nervous
and I imagine that a Christian
would probably feel nervous
in a group of Satanists.
- Actually I have a quick question
about everybody's relationship
with their family,
specifically their parents?
Yeah.
- My dad is the only one of my parents
who knows that I'm Satanist.
My mom is so Christian
and she's constantly
shoving that stuff down my throat, so.
- I'm sorry.
- Yeah. Yeah, it would
be hard to tell her.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- Her backstory about
how she got into Satanism
seemed really kind of shaky to me.
(buzzing)
- What?
You guys are wrong, but, bye.
- Sorry.
- I wish I could say I was surprised,
but I really wasn't.
I think most of it was
because of how I was dressed.
- I had a question for Coco.
I just wanted to ask when
you practice your Satanism
it's mainly personal, you said, right?
Like you don't really
follow the Temple or?
- No, I don't follow TST.
- No. not at all.
But you said
- Too structured for me
you're more towards LaVey and the Church?
- I don't really like being
tethered to anyone's rules
or feel like I'm supposed
to be in any kind of box.
I think the TST does really great work
but I also wish they kind of expanded
'cause a lot of the focus
is on abortion rights
and there's just so much
going on in the world,
with like environmentalism, racism.
- There are a lot of different factions
that focus on different
things and different tenets.
- I was suspicious of Shelby
because they were suspicious of me
and maybe they were trying
to deflect attention
from themselves and
direct it more towards me.
- I have a weird proposal.
Is there possibility that
if we sniff each other
that one person might
smell really different?
And I think it could be pheromones.
- Oh, whoa. Okay.
I mean maybe, I'm into it, but
come, come sniff if you want.
- I'm gonna try it.
(group laughing)
- Go ahead.
- Now. I'm like, I hope I smell good.
- I've got Alien Goddess
perfume on, so I should.
- I mean I'm not going
to be the judge of this.
- I don't know what I'm looking for.
(group chattering)
- I can't trust my nose so
that's not gonna help me at all.
- I'm congested,
I have one nostril that's
not working right now.
- In my mind, I'm kind of questioning Coco
and I'm kind of questioning you,
just because you are a little quiet.
- I'm questioning you because
you haven't talked a lot.
- Well just so you guys know,
in case you have any doubts about me,
I did go viral last year on TikTok
for talking about my satanism.
- I thought you looked familiar.
- Oh my gosh. I'm not on TikTok.
- And I actually know her so.
- I think I'm challenging you
because you kind of speak in generalities
from this round to the last.
You seem like you researched
last minute type of thing.
Maybe I'm wrong.
(bell ringing)
- I wish I had more time to talk.
(upbeat music)
- I thought it was really weird
'cause I thought he would be super smelly
because he is wearing this latex outfit
that would make you really sweaty
but he had no smell at all.
- She just didn't really
do a lot of the talking.
She was kind of hanging in the background.
- [Narrator] We counted all
the votes and there's a tie.
The tie is between Kara and Shelby.
Each of you has 30 seconds
to state your case.
Starting with Shelby.
- So I don't have a
religious background at all.
I was raised completely agnostic.
I really did just have to go about my life
to figure out what it was that I believed
and the core beliefs and the tenets of TST
just are really who I am as a person.
You know, I-
(bell ringing)
- Yeah, no, I mean I
did grow up Christian.
I'm not gonna hide that.
I definitely did.
I, like I said, I also
have a lot of trauma.
I relate to that.
I'm in the stage of
just being really angry.
The tenants really are something
that I strive to live by
because I think organized religion
just causes more harm than
it does actual humanity. So.
(bell ringing)
(buzzing)
- Good luck.
I do realize that I
was being kind of quiet
and I didn't get a lot in to say.
So I wasn't surprised.
- [Narrator] Please raise your hand
if you think that the
mole is still in the box
and you would like to
continue playing the game.
Starting now, for every time
all of you vote out someone
that is not the mole, the total
prize money will be reduced.
- So I'm suspicious of you
because strangely enough you had no smell.
And I was like sniffing
into your armpits and stuff.
I don't know what that means
but that's the only thing
I can go off right now
'cause everyone's giving good answers.
So if we have any questions
that might go on a deeper level.
- Yeah, I actually have one.
- Right?
- This might be a little personal
but what is everybody's kinks and fetishes
because I think-
- Oh, I used to be a dominatrix.
- Satanic Temple people might have those
a little bit more than a Christian.
That's just my bias though.
I'm exploring my kinks more these days.
Like since I've just recently
gotten into a lot of this stuff.
I was also, don't want
to get too personal,
but I was molested as a child
so my sexuality's kind of
been all over the place
and some very bad places and
hopefully now some good places,
some positive, healthy places.
- Okay. Interesting.
- I'm sorry for what happened
to you though. That's awful.
- I do find that a lot of
Christians can be very fetishy
and also very submissive.
I know, I kind of feel
like, she went viral,
I'm definitely have no doubts about you.
I'm married to drag queen,
I'm in the Dark Art Society.
No offense but you would look Christian.
So I don't wanna choose you
because you kind of like
would be too obvious.
You also seem very heartfelt,
but that's the whole point right?
Everyone's lying.
So what do we think at
this point as a group?
- I wasn't suspicious of you before
but now I'm a little
bit suspicious of you.
Just because there's
crossover community, sure.
- I mean vote me out if you want.
It's just less money for you guys.
- Well, I don't wanna share with anybody.
That's very Luciferian.
(laughing)
- I'm not gonna lie.
I had my doubts about
you from the beginning
just because, no.
- Oh me.
- Yes.
- Oh, okay.
- The contacts and everything
it's a little overboard
because we're trying to figure out-
- Those are her eyes.
(laughing)
- Ave seemed just very over confident
and she had all the right answers
and she knew all the terms.
You know, this girl could have researched
over the past week.
- Vote them out already then?
Now I'm like
- Maybe
- I don't think so.
- Okay. Well then who
are you suspicious of?
- I'm still suspicious of these two.
- Ask me questions. How
can I help alleviate that?
- Deny Christ right now.
- I'm an atheist.
- No deny Christ.
Deny the power of the Holy Spirit.
I'll do it.
There's no power in the Holy Spirit.
There's no power in anything.
- I don't believe it.
Yeah I don't believe in any supernatural.
I don't believe in any God figure.
I also agree.
I am a skeptic.
- But do you believe
Jesus is the son of God?
- No
- I do feel a lot more
suspicious of you now
because now I'm convinced by him
because all the blasphemy
that a Christian isn't supposed to do.
And you seem very hesitant.
See you reworded it before
you actually said it.
- Totally that's fair.
- Fool me once, shame on you.
Fool me twice. I mean, she dodged it twice
and she just could not get out from that.
- I mean, again, I'm gonna, I
grew up in that lens. Right?
And that was like day one
that was embedded into me.
And as I just mentioned a few answers ago-
- Like we share a background
in that we were raised Christian,
we have that, you know.
- And I will say with that again,
I think this is a journey and like,
as we talk about psychology
it's like still unpeeling
a lot of layers for me.
So yeah, like maybe a little hesitant
'cause that inner lens,
that like one year old self in me,
is just activated in that
but I'm still learning
to peel back those layers
of what I was raised in.
Does that, does that help make sense?
- Yeah.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- She hesitated.
So to me I think that was the victory.
(buzzing)
- Bye guys.
- Bye.
- I knew when Nathaniel denounced Christ
and suspicion was off him,
that I was absolutely
going to be eliminated.
- [Narrator] Please raise your hand.
If you think that the
mole is still in the box
and you would like to
continue playing the game.
- I'll be very upset.
If a Christian runs out of here $500.
- Yeah, me too.
- [Narrator] If the lights turn green
that means you voted the
mole out and you win.
If the lights turn red,
that means that the mole is
still in the box and you lose.
(suspenseful music)
- Yes.
- Hell yeah.
- Nice job, guys.
- Hail Satan.
- [Narrator] Can the mole
please reveal their identity
in 3, 2, 1.
- What's up guys.
(group chattering)
Got 'em.
(laughing)
- I (bleeping) knew it.
It was Kara the whole time.
I knew it.
- You were wrong about me, okay.
- We were wrong.
- I didn't vote for you.
- I judged the ballet flats. I'm sorry.
- So I identify as Christian,
but it's super deconstructed.
Definitely encourage everyone viewing
to go research Satanism
'cause it's a beautiful thing.
- That makes me so happy
because I was thinking
how could somebody actually research TST
or the Satanic Movement
and not feel like it aligns
with the morals of Christianity.
- No, absolutely.
- Or really any moral structure at all.
Don't listen to the
Satanic panic propaganda.
(laughing)
- I enjoyed everybody.
And the Christian didn't offend me
like I thought they would.
So that was awesome.
- One of the contestants
had asked if I thought
that, you know, Jesus is the son of God.
And I said, no.
So I think I had half of me
that was super competitive
and wanted to win
and then the other half of me
that felt like this is going against
something that I believe.
- I chose to dress this way
and not as Satanist as
possible for a reason.
And that is to show that Satanists
come in all shapes, and sizes, and forms,
and colors, and whatnot.
- It's about embracing counter culture
and taking in the outcasts.
(upbeat music)
- I'm a runway model.